Vice President Mike Pence is in charge
of the White House's coronavirus task
force and he joins us from here in
Washington mr. vice president good
morning thanks for being with us good
morning all mr. vice president the first
the first as we mentioned as Paula
mentioned I want to get to the travel
ban to begin with the first confirmed
case of coronavirus in this country was
back in January on the 21st
why have we waited so long for a travel
ban well as you say when the first case
the coronavirus had emerged in this
country it would be a little more than a
week later that the president took the
unprecedented step of suspending all
travel from China which was the the
originating country of this virus we
also established travel advisories and
and we've been screening passengers on
all direct flights from South Korea and
Italy but with the epicenter of this
epidemic now moving from China and South
Korea to Europe yesterday the president
again took the unprecedented step of
suspending all travel from Europe for
the next 30 days and in in that in
combination with our strong mitigation
efforts in communities that are
experiencing what our experts call
community spread areas of California
Washington State in New York we're going
to continue to put put every effort at
home and with regard to these travel
restrictions in place to protect the
health and safety of the American people
mr. vice president the the president
last night said that Europe has
dramatically more cases of Crona virus
than the United States however how do we
know that when we have not been testing
widely well every state lab in America
is able to conduct tests and we have
three particular jurisdictions that
we're tracking community spread we've
been flowing testing resources into
those areas and and and we'll continue
to do that but make no mistake about all
the new cases in the world this week 70%
of the new cases were in Europe and
the increase has been dramatic when when
the president imposed the travel
advisory and we began screening all
flights all passengers coming into the
United States from Italy two weeks ago
there were roughly 500 coronavirus cases
now there's 12,000 about a thousand in
Germany about a thousand in France
that's the reason why the president
essentially said . we're gonna suspend
all travel and that American citizens
coming home and legal residents will be
funneled through 13 different airports
they'll get an initial health screening
coming in but we're also going to ask
everyone returning to our country to
self quarantine for 14 days so testing
is happening in every state lab in the
country many University Hospitals have
taken the FDA tests like the University
of Washington is doing a great job
expanding testing capabilities but the
biggest piece on the testing is that our
commercial labs that the president
brought in last week companies like
quest and lab core have already had
approved a new test that they several
days ago have begun to take to market
which they can do in a vast and
expansive way across the country and
literally in the days ahead we're going
to continue to see the availability of
tests at your local doctor ultimately at
your local pharmacy continue to expand
with mr. vice president the governor of
New York was of course dealing with a
significant outbreak of cases said that
there are two ways to reduce this
massive quarantine massive testing and
he said we can't rely on the CDC or the
FDA that they become a bottleneck and
testing is taking too long well I spoke
with Governor Cuomo last night in
connection with some guidance that CDC
just issued to New York and Washington
state in California we've we put out
very very strong recommendations for
social distancing for large gatherings
for schools and we're working in very
close cooperation with the state of New
York and the governor of Iowa also
talked about the the fact that we are we
are working for the
volume testing to be approved the state
lab in New York State is already able to
do that as the governor and I discussed
earlier this week we're working to
expand that to other state labs and the
American people can be confident we are
going to continue to work in every way
to clear out as the president said any
red tape any barriers to testing that
might have existed at the FDA and make
it possible for State labs university
hospitals as well as these commercial
laboratories I can't emphasize enough if
you go to the website for the company's
quest or lab core you can already see
they're providing resources information
where healthcare providers can obtain
tests and that's literally expanding by
the day mr. vice-president that's
heartening news for many people I'm sure
but just to put this all in context
China at this point had about 300,000
tests out there South Korea 200,000
tests we have on the official count 7700
so why are we so far behind should we
have begun this testing earlier because
if you don't test you don't catch the
milder cases you can never contain this
thing well I think it is an issue since
I was tapped to lead this effort two
weeks ago by the president here at the
White House that we've put real focus on
and the the fact is that every state
laboratory in the country now for some
time since the advent of the corona
virus in this country has been able to
conduct their own coronavirus tests but
the truth is they are not required to
report that testing to the CDC as you
have to do in the case of many diseases
and so it's a voluntary reporting right
now we're working to we're working to
adjust that so that we're getting the
full information from every state lab
but anyone anyone of you errs this
morning that might be concerned that
they were exposed to the corona virus or
to someone who had it or if they have
symptoms they can call their doctor
their doctor can contact their state lab
and they'll be able to find out how they
and obtain a test in all 50 states tests
are being conducted and as I said at the
president's Direction we're working to
expand that very broadly all across the
country in cooperation with our
incredible commercial laboratories and
the president has said that every
American he wants to get tested can't
get tested but that's simply not true
from what we're hearing from our own
medical contributors health officials
from New Jersey told Congress on Tuesday
that the state of about nine million
people has only received two test kits
so when will the states get these kids
well I think what the president was
referring to there was something that
governor jay Inslee of Washington State
called to our attention about two weeks
ago and that was that many health
professionals interpreted CDC guidance
to say that if you were only mildly
symptomatic that a doctor would not have
the authority to recommend a coronavirus
test we changed that a CDC sent out very
clear guidelines so that now if you call
your doctor regardless of your symptoms
a doctor can order without hesitation a
test they can contact the state
laboratory and as I said we're
continuing to expand the availability
and literally we're literally going to
expand to hundreds of thousands of more
tests in the days and weeks ahead all
across the country but mr. president's
focus last night was to say we we need
to suspend all travel from Europe
because we do know now that the
epicenter of the corona virus is Europe
and that when we look over the last 36
hours of the 35 states yesterday early
in the day that had coronavirus cases 30
of those actually could be could be tied
to contacts with Europe so the president
said . and on any travel incoming mr.
president and but we're also marrying
that to all of our mitigation efforts
particularly in the communities where we
have community spread that makes every
American can help by practicing common
sense and good hygiene that's a cordless
or whether there's a coronavirus case in
your community absolutely correct that's
a good note to end on we've got to leave
it there
Vice President Prince thank you very
much we hope to talk to you again real
soon